le projet de loi de bioéthique en débat
ce matin je reçois danièle obono député
la france a soumises de paris et
philippe vigier député modem
d'eure-et-loir
[Musique]
bonjour danièle obono bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france vous êtes face à
philippe vigier ce matin merci et et
bonjour philippe vigier d'être avec nous
dans la matinale d'ayrté france toujours
si besoin des centristes d'eure-et-loir
député sentent bon jour et pas modem
toutes mes excuses
on va commencer ce débat avec le même
groupe d'appartenance du sort très bien
on va commencer avec vous danièle obono
lille et verront s'est dit confiant sur
une application de cette loi d'ici à
septembre est ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour vous là disons qu'il était
temps parce que c'est quand même un
processus qui a été très long et qui
signifie très concrètement pour des
dizaines de parents qui souhaitent être
parents de personnes qui souhaitent être
parent d'avoir attendu trois ans pour
pouvoir enfin avoir accès à un droit qui
aurait dû leur être accordée en même
temps que les couples hétérosexuels et
pour ce qui est des des femmes
homosexuelles et puis pour les pour les
femmes seules également donc on a eu un
processus très longue d'autant plus
qu'il n'était pas nécessaire d'ailleurs
que la question de la pme soit incluse
dans une voie bioéthique c'est ça qui a
le choix de la majorité qui a retardé
pour pour beaucoup l'adoption l'adoption
de cette mesure donc il était temps et
il est temps effectivement que l'égalité
soit acquise pour pour tous et toutes
philippe vigier vous êtes d'accord avec
ça
mise en application peut être à la
rentrée il a fallu plus de trois ans
effectivement pour ce n'est pas fini
d'ailleurs le le processus parlementaire
va se poursuivre encore au sénat est ce
que cette réforme et est allée est allé
suffisamment vite selon vous ou pas ou
fallait-il autant arrêter d'écouter
c'est un nouveau droit qui est donné aux
femmes homosexuelles aux femmes qui sont
eux jean couple on sait que ce sont
toujours des débats sociétaux sont des
débats qui sont longs l'important ce qu
on enlève pas un droit aux couples
hétérosexuels qui ont accès à la paix et
my pour laquelle d'ailleurs tiens à dire
qu'il ya encore des coups hétérosexuels
qui n'ont toujours pas accès la tma
parce qu'il faudrait plus de 100 des pma
mieux répartis sur le territoire
avec ce texte nous allons voter c'est un
droit qui est ouvert aux femmes seules
aux femmes homosexuelles dans ses droits
supplémentaires sans pour autant que
personne n'y gagne rien alors il ya des
questions importantes qui se posent
moi je suis favorable t.mg.a opposé à la
gpa gestation pour autrui pourquoi parce
que là ça devient une marchandisation du
corps autant on peut comprendre un
souhait d'accueillir un enfant au sol
des familles composées par exemple de
deux femmes
autant je suis pas du tout d'accord pour
que justement cette gestation pour
autrui puisse être mise en place
donc c'est une avancée mais toutes ces
questions là sont des questions qui sont
pas simples pour appel à la conscience
de chacun
je suis un nous origines familiales la
façon dont on aborde ces questions sont
les questions qui sont difficiles à
appréhender mais je crois que c'est
essentiel de se pencher sur aussi cette
capacité que l'on peut donner la vie
peut-être pas sur le mode c'est qu'il
était connu auparavant c'était toujours
ah père et une mère qui était la
meilleure je rappelle et tout le monde
l'a oublié qu'une femme seule peut
adopter un enfant et qu'un homme seul
peut adopter un enfant sans je trouve
pas du tout anormal qu'une femme seule
qui peut voir un jour avoir envie d'un
enfant soucis après faut donner le
donneur et pour autant rien n'est changé
concernant les conservations de gamètes
simplement il faut bien comprendre que
le don de
manuellement de vaud suite j'espère être
celui dans ce pays est gratuit et je
tiens à ce qu'ils restent totalement
gratuit alors l'exécutif a rappelé
qu'ils ne maintiendraient cette recette
ligne rouge de la gestation pour autrui
il n'en est pas question pour le moment
danièle obono est ce que cette réforme
va assez loin selon vous il reste un
certain nombre de points je veux juste
rappeler que on parle d'une mesure la
pme l'accès à la pma dans une loi
bioéthique qui n'avait pas sa place dans
la question bioéthique puisque la
question politique a été résolu en 94
c'était une loi c'est ça devrait être
une voie plus rapide une loi d'égalité
et dans cette loi des qualités qui était
déjà attendu sous le quinquennat
précédent parce que c'est pas juste les
quatre dernières années ça fait
plusieurs années que ça aurait dû être
mise en oeuvre
il y a encore malheureusement des
manques en termes d'égalité je pense
notamment à la question des personnes
trans qui sont aussi concernés et qui
n'ont pas aujourd'hui tous l'acceptent
qu'elle pourrait avoir à ceux à ce droit
également selon leur degré de transition
selon qu'elles soient en couple ou pas
donc on voit qu'il ya encore des
questions en termes d'égalité et
d'universalité véritablement de cet
accès et je crois que de ce point de vue
là c'est peut-être ça qui va rester
comme un goût d'inachevé
en tout cas pour toutes celles et ceux
qui attendent depuis très longtemps
cette mesure de la pma et les couples
d'hommes homosexuels non plus évidemment
puisqu'il y aurait un recours inévitable
à la gpa
philippe vigier pour vous cette réforme
va assez loin ou faut-il s'en tenir à ce
qui a été décidé édulcoré d'ailleurs par
par le sénat que des porcs une fois le
il ya eu un engagement politique a été
pris pour les pays d'ancienne il l'est
tenu d'une belle contesté pour certains
ça ne va pas assez loin
moi je trouve qu'on encadre bien les
choses moi qui suis biologiste je peux
vous dire que la pma pour des couples
hétérosexuels je répète ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure on imprime de donneurs on
a un problème d'accès à la pma pour cet
homme de famille et puis avec cette loi
on évitera que certains liés à
l'étranger faire des procréations
médicalement assistées revenait en
france déclaré une grossesse et tout ça
se faisait sous le manteau donc au moins
aussi on va faire une sorte de
régularisation des choses pour autant
pour moyenne milieu rouge une frontière
très forte c'est celle de la gpa que je
ne franchirai jamais je tiens à le dire
je peux comprendre a besoin souhait
d'avoir un enfant mais avoir un enfant
ce n'est pas se faire plaisir c'est
c'est beaucoup plus fort que ça c'est
donner la vie donner la vie c'est un
être un garçon une fille qui va grandir
qui devra ensuite s'épanouir qui devra
ensuite elle à son tueur constituer une
famille crois que c'est une grève très
belle avancée mais n'oublions pas je me
permets de le répéter
danièle obono hellal c'est très bien
comme moi plus incertain départements
d'outre-mer territoire du trailer mais
dans certains d'autres départements de
france dans mon propre département et
bien l'accueil pour les femmes
hétérosexuelles ou homosexuelles ans
bientôt dans quelques mois en pma n'est
pas satisfait donc on a beaucoup à faire
et puis sur le don le don de sperme sur
le don d'ovocytes
là il faut progresser c'est un acte
d'une générosité extraordinaire
il faut continuer parce que on risque
d'avoir des manques
quelquefois de donneurs et ça c'est un
enjeu national où ces commis don
d'organes c'est comme le dos de sang
fait souvent appel d'ailleurs lorsque
l'été arrive aux donneurs du sang
c'est une particularité de la prendre
cette générosité qu'ils incarnent au don
d'organes et gratuit le don de de tous
et de sperme naturellement deux dossiers
de don de sang est gratuit gardons cette
spécificité française
donc c'est une loi qui permet d'avancer
sur la pma qui permet de répondre à un
engagements qui avaient été pris on peut
toujours déplorer la lenteur mais voyez
moi je regarde plutôt le verre plein que
je regarde le verbe id
c'est une avancée il faut je crois dire
que engagements tenus et ça mérite
d'être souligné avec force la paix avec
ce ne sera pas remboursé en dehors de
raisons médicales danièle obono c'est
une régression pour vous c'est le sénat
qui a qui l'a voulu je pense que sur ce
point on devrait arriver à un retour au
texte de l'assemblée
je tenais à dire qu'on ne parle pas ici
vous n'y avez fait pour référence à
plusieurs reprises son papa de la gpa la
gpa ne va pas être autorisé personne ne
le demande
à cette heure est donc on parle de la
pma et donc il s'agit il s'agit bien
dans ce texte de loi bioéthique de
rendre accessible une technique qu'il
est déjà en fête pour les couples
hétérosexuels et qui hérite fr était
restée fermée aux femmes homosexuelles
et aux femmes seules donc il s'agissait
d'une discrimination qu'on va on va
remettre en cause et donc dans ce cas
effectivement il n'y a pas de raison que
ce ne soit pas plus ce ne soit pas
remboursé pour les uns alors que ça mais
pour les autres je crois que si on doit
faire l'égalité au moins de ce point de
vue là encore une fois en malgré le fait
que les personnes trans soit exclue
encore pour certaines d'entre elles on
doit faire l'égalité pour tout le monde
et donc le remboursement pour tous que
ce que l'on soit un couple hétérosexuel
ou un couple homosexuel ou une femme
seul ça doit être la même règle pour
tous et la même prise en charge pour
tous et toutes le danièle obono les
associations lgbt craignent une
discrimination car il pourrait y avoir
une possible inscription de sur l'acte
de naissance de la main
sion du couple lesbien qu'en pensez vous
je crois également que il s'agit là en
fait d'une concession de la majorité aux
secteurs les plus les plus conservateurs
et c'est un problème parce que
effectivement encore une fois de mon
point de vue il n'y a pas de raison que
soient ainsi signifier une forme de
différence selon qu'on a un enfant qui
est conçue par un couple hétérosexuel ou
un enfant qui est conçue par un couple
homosexuel ligne à véritablement aucune
justification que cette mention soit
indiquée il était possible et nous nous
l'avons défendue de faire en sorte qu'on
aligne tout simplement le régime pour
les couples homosexuels sur ce qui est
fait on avait la possibilité de faire
une filiation beaucoup plus simple et je
crois malheureusement que c'est une idée
des concessions que la majorité le
gouvernement a décidé de faire à la
droite et ce qui est encore une des
scories qui restera dans 16 mois
malgré le fait qu'elle est finalement
adopté un fils vigier il nous reste
quelques minutes il ya également à la
délicate réforme de la filiation dans ce
projet de loi et l'accès aux origines
qui est maintenant ouvert est-ce que
cela ne risque pas d'ouvrir une boîte de
pandore 1 en c1 c'est une une demande de
nombre d'enfants qui sont nés par ce
biais d'abord un mot sur ce qu a dit
daniel et bono nous allons revenir sur
le texte de l'assemblée qui prévoira un
remboursement de cet ep ma pour les
couples homosexuels
et c'est normal puisque il ya le
remboursement pour les couples
hétérosexuels
je vais parce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure ouvrons les yeux il se passe à
l'heure actuelle c'est quoi ces des
femmes allaient justement ces cars
inséminer en espagne et en angleterre
est revenu en france déclaré une
grossesse été remboursés donc ceux qui
vous disent que c'est un scandale ce
soit ceux remboursés
il vient de les yeux sur le fait que ces
pratiques et elle se faisait sous le
manteau donc moyer je préfère avec a
beaucoup de transparence dire les choses
très simplement également avec des
robots géants partager le fait que nous
sommes proposées
et l'autre totalement à la gpa bas et en
belgique je le suis vraiment affirmant
fermement
enfin secret de la filiation puisque mme
interrogé là-dessus ces évolutions mais
je rappelle qu' il y a la possibilité
pour le donneur s'il ne veut pas
décliner son identité bien de conserver
cet anonymat ya pas de caractère
obligatoire et une possibilité ouverte
de savoir qui était le donneur
mais si le donneur ne veut pas dire qui
c'est lui qui a souhaité faire ce nom et
bien ce secret et réservé donc c'est pas
du tout une boîte de pandore c'est une
croix là-dessus un texte équilibré faut
pas vouloir faire du robot de chances
qu'ils n'ont pas la loi c'était un sujet
de discussion a duré de longues heures à
l'assemblée sur cette question là
entre ceux qui voulaient vraiment que
l'animation est enlevée
d'autres qui voulaient que l'on reste
sur le statu quo la solution à laquelle
nous sommes arrivés préserve à la fois
le sceau de l'anonymat suc souhaite le
garder
le seuil de savoir pour un enfant qui
étaient les géniteurs et ça sera
possible possibilités ouvertes ont
franchement on te parler plus loin
c'était équilibré et je crois que chacun
comme cela pas s'y retrouver
1550 amendement il ya encore du travail
philippe vigier rien sur la fin on
devient danièle obono le disais c'est
une loi un peu fourre tout c'est pas du
tout fort tous nés mélangeons pas tout
la famille ville discussions l'autre
jour écoutez vous n'êtes dire l'instant
1550 amendements étudiés l'assemblée
nationale sur une journée l'audio il ya
déjà deux mille cinq cents amendements
sur le premier article si vous faites un
texte avec 20 articles qui traitent de x
questions sociétales vous aurez vingt
mille amendements ça n'a pas de sens
1 la loi elle doit être précise la loi
elle peut pas traiter de cinq questions
en même temps là c'était un sujet majeur
est ce que oui ou non on ouvre la gpa
pour les fans seul positif à mon cou
question sur laquelle j'ai évolué tiens
à le dire le termine termine en disant
que peut pas dans un texte non mais
c'est important pour la compréhension
pour les téléspectateurs avaient qui
comprennent pas pourquoi ensuite les
6000 8000 dix mille amendements si vous
faites un fourre-tout tout le monde la
soirée sur tous les sujets et à partir
de là ça devient un texte vise il est
inaudible
c'est important de presse
et pour la compréhension de la loi
danièle obono merci vigier danièle obono
le mot de la fin ils voient ce quelques
secondes oui je pense que encore une
fois ça a été le choix de la majorité de
m à la question de la pma qui est une
question d'égalité et pas de bioéthique
dans ce texte est effectivement d'une
part elle a la majorité a également
choisi de ne pas traiter de questions
qui sont par ailleurs des questions
bioéthiques comme la question de la fin
de vie digne
mais également comme la question de
l'interdiction des mutilations de
personnes intersexe et là on a un sujet
véritablement bioéthique qui aurait dû
être traité et donc effectivement
explique le nombre d'amendements qui
s'est focalisé sur la question de la pma
alors qu'il y avait effectivement des
sujets importants bioéthique sur
lesquels on aurait pu avancer et ça
c'est effectivement dommage
une raison de plus pour faire en sorte
que lors du prochain mandat en 2020 dont
on puisse avoir enfin une scène vide
qu'ils soient permises par l'assemblée
la nouvelle majorité
et puis notamment des questions comme
l'interdiction des mutilations des
personnes intersexe merci beaucoup
danièle obono et merci également à
philippe vigier qui étaient avec nous
pour ce débat sur qui n'en était pas
vraiment un on l'a vu en tout cas merci
d'avoir apporté vos points de vue
respectifs sur la question de la loi
bioéthique en direct dans la matinale ce
matin